♪ ♪
>> Dana: PRESIDENT TRUMP
PRESSURING DEMOCRATS TO RETURN
TO WASHINGTON TO HELP MILLIONS
OF SEPARATING AMERICANS.
HOUSE DEMOCRATS WAY THAT IT
COULD BE DANGEROUS TO RETURN TO
WORK.
BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS A
DIFFERENT THEORY.
>> WOULD DEMOCRATS, THEY DON’T
WANT TO COME BACK.
THEY DON’T WANT TO COME BACK.
THEY SHOULD BE BACK HERE, BUT
THEY DON’T.
THEY ARE ENJOYING THEIR
VACATION.
AND THEY SHOULD NOT BE BECAUSE
OF NANCY PELOSI EATING ICE CREAM
ON LATE-NIGHT TELEVISION.
>> Dana: SO, KENNEDY, IT IS
PRETTY SAFE GROUND TO MAKE FUN
OF DEMOCRATS FOR NOT WANTING TO
COME BACK, BECAUSE THEY THINK
THAT CONGRESS DOES NOT DO
ANYTHING ANYWAY.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THIS POINT THAT
THE DEMOCRATS SAY THAT THEIR
DOCTOR TOLD THEM THAT IT WOULD
NOT BE A GOOD IDEA, HOW DO THEY
WEIGH THAT?
>> Kennedy: THEY SOCIALLY
DISTANCE, THEY WEAR FACE MASKS,
THEY WASH THEIR HANDS, AND THEY
DON’T TOUCH THEIR FACE, AND THEY
DO CRITICAL WORK, BECAUSE THEY
ARE DECIDING WHO LIVES AND DIES
RIGHT NOW.
THAT IS THE IMPORTANT REALITY.
IT IS EASY FOR THEM TO STAY IN
QUARANTINE FOR THE MOST PART BY
AND LARGE THEIR GILDED TOWERS
AND EXPECT PEOPLE TO WORK IN
NURSING HOMES AND HOSPITALS AND
FIRE AND POLICE STATIONS, AND
AAA.
THOMAS MASSIE HAS BEEN VERY
ENTERTAINING ON THIS.
HE WANTS TO GET BACK TO WORK.
HE IS CHALLENGING PEOPLE TO GET
BACK TO WORK.
HOUSE DEMOCRATS SAY THEY DON’T
HAVE ANY LEGISLATION, SO WHY
SHOULD THEY HURRY BACK TO CRAFT
LEGISLATION?
DO SOMETHING BETTER AND MAKE
YOUR CONSTITUENTS FEEL LIKE YOU
CARE ABOUT THEM.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE THINGS
THEY COULD DO IS SENATORS
PORTMAN AND DURBIN HAVE PROPOSED
A WAY FOR THE SENATORS AND
CONGRESS TO BE ABLE TO VOTE BY
PROXY OR FROM AFAR, AND THERE IS
SO MUCH RESISTANCE TO THAT, I
MEAN, DOESN’T IT SEEM LIKE THERE
IS A TECHNICAL SOLUTION HERE?
>> Juan: I THINK THERE IS.
IT’S PRETTY CLEAR WHAT YOU LAID
OUT, DANA, THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THERE IS A LOT OF PREDICTION
ABOUT PEOPLE SHOWING UP IN
PERSON IN CONGRESS TO DO THE
WORK.
WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT IS A
4.8 SHRINKAGE IN TERMS OF GDP
GROSS DOMESTIC PRODUCT OVER THE
LAST QUARTER.
THAT’S TERRIBLE.
I DON’T THINK YOU CAN BLAME
REPUBLICANS OR DEMOCRATS, AND I
SURE DON’T THINK ANYBODY CAN DO
ANYTHING BUT BLAME THE VIRUS.
LET’S BE CLEAR.
AND WHEN IT COMES TO CONGRESS,
AND THE PRESIDENTS NASTY LITTLE
COMMENT ABOUT ICE CREAM AND
ENJOYING THEIR VACATION, I DON’T
UNDERSTAND, BECAUSE, DEMOCRATS
IN FACT WITH REPUBLICANS HAVE
PASSED FOUR LARGE BILLS, TWO OF
THEM WITH HUGE SPENDING INTENDED
TO DEAL WITH THE ISSUE.
AND THE DEMOCRATS WORK VERY HARD
TO THE POINT THAT SOME
REPUBLICANS SAID, OH, YOU’RE
SLOWING IT DOWN BY MAKING THESE
DEMANDS, AND THESE DEMANDS ARE
NOT DIRECTLY RELATED.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS ARE WORKING TO
GET AN MONEY FOR HOSPITALS, FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE POOR AND HUNGRY
IN THIS COUNTRY.
I THINK THAT YOU CAN, EVEN IF
YOU ARE A HARD LINE, MAKE A
CASE.
I DON’T THINK THAT’S A FAIR
ARGUMENT.
AND I THINK THAT I WOULD AGREE
WITH KENNEDY ON PEOPLE COMING
BACK.
IF YOU CAN GET ONE OR TWO
STAFFERS IN THERE, GO TO WORK.
>> Dana: GREG, THEY ALREADY
KNOW THAT THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO DO MORE GOING FORWARD, AND
THEY HAVE NOT HAD ANY COMMITTING
MEANINGS, THEY CANNOT DO ANY OF
THE WORK, EVEN IF THEY WANTED TO
DO OVERSIGHT, THEY COULD NOT DO
THAT.
YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> Greg: THIS IS HARD, BECAUSE
I DON’T WANT THEM TO WORK, YOU
KNOW?
BECAUSE I JUST DON’T WANT TO
THEM TO WORK.
HOWEVER, THE FOUNDING FATHERS
ASSUMED, BECAUSE YOU KNOW THAT I
AM AN EXPERT ON THE FOUNDING
FATHERS, THAT PEOPLE HAD TO BE
PRESENT IN THE CAPITAL TO WORK.
BUT THERE ARE A FEW THINGS THAT
HAVE HAPPENED SINCE THEN.
THERE ARE THESE THINGS CALLED
COMPUTERS, AND YOU CAN GET ON
THE INTERNET, AND YOU CAN DO
STUFF FROM AFAR.
I JUST ORDERED LIKE $100 WORTH
OF RECORDS.
THESE GUYS IN THEIR OLD FACTS,
AND THEY ARE UNHEALTHY, THEY
STAY HOME AND WORK FROM HOME,
AND YOU CAN PASS ALL OF THE
MONEY FROM THERE.
I THINK IT IS TIME THAT WE
CHANGE THE TRADITIONS TO REFLECT
THE REALITY THAT THERE IS.
AND I AGREE WITH JUAN, THE
ECONOMY, 4.8%?
THE ARGUMENT THAT THIS IS AN
EVIL CAPITALIST SOCIETY
PROPAGATED ON THE AMERICAN
CAMPUSES FIVE.
PROFESSORS WHO
READ NOTHING BUT HOWARD ZINN,
HOW IS IT THAT THIS EVIL, GREEDY
SOCIETY SACRIFICING ITS ECONOMY
TO SAVE THE MOST VULNERABLE
PEOPLE?
I MEAN, EVEN SWEDEN THE MODEL OF
COOL SOCIALISM DID NOT EVEN DO
THAT.
BUT HERE, FAT CAT AMERICA IS
SOMETHING SO INCREDIBLE, IT IS
SO INCREDIBLE, AND WE TAKE IT
FOR GRANTED AND WE NEED TO
REMIND OURSELVES OF THAT.
MAYBE.
>> Dana: JESSE, DO YOU THINK
THAT THE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
NEED TO GET BACK?
>> Jesse: I DO.
DO YOU REMEMBER WHEN NANCY TRIED
TO LEAVE THE COUNTRY ON A JUDGE
AND THE PRESIDENT GROUNDED THE
JET?
I THINK THIS TIME HE SHOULD SEND
THE JET TO NANCY, STOCK IT FULL
OF ICE CREAM AND SAY, AND FIVE
WE ARE GOING WHEELS UP, AND I
WILL GIVE YOU A LIFT BACK TO
D.C.
I MEAN, SHE IS LIKE THE MOST
POWERFUL WOMAN IN THE WORLD, AND
SHE IS SITTING HIDING IN HER
MANSION.
YOU CAN’T SAY THE PRESIDENT IS
NOT LEADING AND THEN HIDE IN
YOUR MANSION.
IT’S NOT A GOOD LOOK, ESPECIALLY
WHEN THE SENATE IS COMING BACK
TO WORK.
SHE IS BASICALLY ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT SHE IS NOT AN ESSENTIAL
EMPLOYEE.
AND MOST OF THE TIME,
CONGRESSMAN ARNDT, BUT NOW THEY
ARE.
SHE COULD DO CHINA,
INFRASTRUCTURE, SHE COULD DO
TESTING.
SHE COULD CREATE TONS OF
LEGISLATION.
IT WILL BE A SYMBOLIC MOVE TO
SHOW THE CONGRESS WORKING AGAIN.
THEY SHOULD BE ON THE FRONT
LINES ALONG WITH EVERYBODY ELSE.
I JUST HOPE NANCY DOESN’T WANT
TO STAY AT HOME BECAUSE SHE
DOESN’T WANT TO HELP THE
RECOVERY OR VISUALLY ASSOCIATE
HERSELF WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT RESPONSE.